ein imposanter bau in england mit einer
besonderen vergangenheit man fühlt sich
dort wie in einer anderen welt oben ist
es eindeutig eine medizinische
einrichtung aber unten wird es ganz
anders es muss einmal ein wichtiger ort
gewesen sein
eine alte fabrik anlage in den usa die
in der bürgerrechtsbewegung eine
wichtige rolle spielte
es ist als sei man geschrumpft und in
ein auto montag gepfercht worden umgeben
von hohen zielen und brennkammern
ein karibisches paradies mit einer
dunklen vergangenheit
erst in diese industrie sollte die
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
struktur des westens verändern
und eine mittelmeerinsel mit bröckelnden
gebäuden und einem labyrinth
unterirdischer tunnel
es ist eine geisterstadt oder genauer
gesagt eine geisterinsel
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
an der küste des ärmelkanals im süden
englands steht ein imposanter alter
gebäudekomplex
doch hier ist von der architektur her
muss der bau einige jahrhunderte alt
sein und eine menge geld gekostet haben
auf den ersten blick wird der komplex
imposant und prunkvoll aber erscheint
auch ein altes geheimnis zu verbergen
innen finden sich unterschiedlich
genutzte bereiche
oben ist es eindeutig eine medizinische
einrichtung aber unten im keller wirkt
das ganz anders dort ist es dunkel die
räume sind klein und die fenster
vergittert
oben und unten passen nicht so recht
zusammen
wenn man sich mit der geschichte des
gebäudes beschäftigt erkennt man wie
sehr sich der ort im laufe der zeit
verändert hat
im moment hat seine glanzzeit hatte der
komplex während des zweiten weltkriegs
damals wurde ihm eine höchst
verantwortliche rolle zu teilen
was also hat es mit diesem ort auf sich
und warum konnte er im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert so zur geltung kommen
hinter einer mauer im südwestlichen
winkel des geländes liegt eine unbebaute
und auf den ersten blick ganz normale
wiesn aber bei näherer betrachtung
finden sich hier hinweise auf die
geschichte dieses orts
lokal historiker eric borbeck hat sich
jahrelangen damit beschäftigt
[Musik]
unter meinen füßen liegen tausende von
toten
es sollen mehr als 20.000 sein
eine archäologische grabung im jahr 2005
brachte nähere erkenntnisse darüber
woran die leute gestorben sind und wie
sie beerdigt worden
einige leichen vielen gliedmaßen andere
sind von schrecklichen krankheiten
gezeichnet
einige starben wohl an so vieles bei
anderen können wir nur raten was die
ursache ihres todes war
auffällig ist dass sie übereinander
begraben wurden wir sind auf eine reihe
von särgen gestoßen bei denen fünf wagen
ineinander zusammengesackt sind
die menschlichen überreste liefern
hinweise darauf welchen zweck diese
gebäude einst erfüllten
hier wurden auch frauen und kinder
begraben es gibt sogar einige russische
leichen was interessant ist aber die
große mehrheit der hier beerdigten
menschen waren vor ihrem tod britische
soldaten
dies ist das royal hospital hasler der
britischen marine erbaut
für die damalige zeit war es ein
riesengroßer bau das größte wachstum
gebäude in ganz europa
anders zeigt wie dringend zu einer
einrichtung in jener zeit benötigt wurde
wie war auf menschen angewiesen
ohne leute funktioniert die flotte nicht
also musste man die verletzten und
kranken irgendwo behandeln können auch
um sie wieder einsatzfähig zu machen
überall auf dem gelände finden sich
hinweise darauf dass dies kein
gewöhnliches krankenhaus für gewöhnliche
patienten war
aufgrund seiner lage ist der ort
hervorragend zu verteidigen aber
gleichzeitig kann man hier menschen gut
festhalten die anlage ist zu drei seiten
von wasser umgeben und rundherum stehen
wachtürme
damals voller rekruten aber sie hatten
keinen einberufungsbefehl von bekommen
sondern einen hausbesuch von fünf typen
die ihn mit knüppeln als überzogen und
sie an bord eines schiffes ihrer
majestät verschleppen
diese zwangs rekrutierten witterten ihre
große chance dem harten leben auf see zu
entkommen wenn sie an land kamen
es gab häufig fluchtversuche ob durch
die kanalisation oder überzeugt sie
liebten es darauf an sich irgendwie raus
zu schmuggeln
wer diesem ort und der royal navy
entkommen wollte versuchte es auf jedem
nur denkbaren weg
aber für die meisten neuankömmlinge gibt
es wenig hoffnungen auf flucht
zunächst einmal gilt es zu überleben
hier soll auch eine englische
redewendung entstanden sein die
patienten wurden über einen fluss im
ruderboot direkt hierher gebracht wer
abhauen wollte war ohne paddel natürlich
aufgeschmissen oder wie man im
englischen sagt
[Musik]
nur wenige jahrzehnte nach der eröffnung
bringen die schlachten der
napoleonischen kriege darunter die bei
trafalgar und hallo das hospital hasler
an seine belastungsgrenze die
verwundeten kommen nun nicht mehr im
ruderboot über den fluss sondern in
scharen direkt von den box
als die patientin ankamen war hier alles
voll von ihnen sie lagen auf dem
steinboden oder lehnten an den wänden
einige hatten sich starke schmerzen und
spielen es gibt aufzeichnungen denen
zufolge an einem einzigen tag 88 leichen
begraben werden mussten so hoch waren
die verluste neben all den anderen
vielen verletzten die zustände müssen
chaotisch gewesen sein
people who die verletzungen stammten
unter anderem von kanonenkugeln die
einem das bein oder den arm abreißen
konnten oder von großen messer schaffen
holzstücken die aus schiffs wänden
gesprengt wurden
waren blut erbrochenes und gedärme
damals wurden die patienten noch nicht
nach der schwere ihrer verletzungen
vorsortiert man behandelte sie einfach
der reihe nach egal ob es sich um einen
notfall handelte oder nicht
das ist der empfangsraum mann hob den
patienten vom boden auf und brachte ihn
hinein so dass der arzt in augenschein
nehmen konnte damals war die behandlung
er brutal egal ob es amputationen
schwere verletzungen oder knochenbrüche
waren alles wurde ohne betäubung
behandelt es gab nicht mal einen schluck
rum
für jene unglücklichen die nach hasler
gebracht wurden war das überleben alles
andere als sicher auch während des
neunzehnten und frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts kamen weiterhin kranke und
verwundete hierher dann stand hasler vor
einer großen herausforderung
denn der ort sollte bei einem der
ehrgeizigsten und geheimsten
angriffspläne aller zeiten eine wichtige
rolle übernehmen während des zweiten
weltkriegs erhielt die belegschaft des
royal hospital hat eine merkwürdige
anweisung der behörden wonach alle
patienten die einrichtung verlassen
sollten
plötzlich näherten sich die stationen
und es herrschte eine seltsame
atmosphäre viele angestellte beschrieben
sie als fast schon unheimlich es waren
keine patienten mehr vor ort aber die
belegschaft sollte da bleiben nur wofür
das wusste niemand
zur angespannten atmosphäre trug bei
dass sich im nahe gelegenen hafen von
portsmouth zahlreiche schiffe und
truppenverbände sammelten etwas
einzigartiges stand kurz bevor all das
war teil der vorbereitungen für den die
idee die invasion in der normandie die
wichtigste militäroperationen des
zweiten weltkriegs am 6 juni 1944 landen
mehr als 150.000 soldaten an den
stränden nordfrankreichs in ihren
planungen für den die decke die
westalliierten davon aus dass 50 prozent
aller truppen am strand getötet oder
verwundet wurde die verwundeten sollten
direkt zurück über den ärmelkanal
gebracht und versorgt werden
dass so viele derer die verletzt wurden
und das glück hatten den tag zu
überleben kamen nach hasler
zu dieser zeit waren die medizinischen
standards erfreulicherweise sehr viel
höher als zur zeit der inbetriebnahme
hier im keller befanden sich die op es
in dem einen gab es drei tische einen
hier einen dort und einen dort so dass
gleichzeitig drei operationen
durchgeführt und so viele verwundete wie
möglich schnell versorgt werden konnten
nebenan wurde ein zweiter operationssaal
eingerichtet
die belegschaft arbeitete rund um die
uhr in acht stunden schichten oft unter
schwierigsten bedingungen
es war ein großes glück dass es lagarde
denn in diesen keller räumen mit ihren
dicken wänden war man sicher so konnten
die verwundeten hier operiert behandelt
und versorgt werden und sobald sie auf
dem weg der besserung waren wurden sie
mit hilfe eines lazarett zugs verlegt
per post kamen zahllose dankesbriefe mit
das militär musste sich um seine leute
kümmern dieser ort wurde sehr geschätzt
die leute schrieben in briefen darüber
waren von der qualität der behandlung
hier sehr beeindruckt
hey wie setzte den betrieb der klinik
während des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
fort dort wurden auch verwundete aus dem
falklandkrieg versorgt ab den 1990 er
jahren wurden hier auch angehörige
anderer teilstreitkräfte behandelt
was sich heute noch hier findet stammt
größtenteils aus der letzten phase der
klinik als sie vom staatlichen national
health service dem nhl es betrieben
wurde
2007 übernahm der nhl es das krankenhaus
in
haslach 254 jahren im dienste des
militärs schloss das klinikum aber nur
zwei jahre später seine pforten
[Musik]
heute wird auf dem klinikgelände ein
wohnprojekt entwickelt die historischen
gebäude sollen dabei erhalten bleiben
und im mittelpunkt stehen
ich habe hier 55 jahre lang gearbeitet
und hänge sehr an diesem bau genau wie
viele meiner freunde und kollegen die
hier tätig waren tesla ist häßler und
wird auch immer häßler bleiben auch wenn
es im rahmen eines neubaugebiets einen
neuen look bekommen wird ich bin sicher
dass es häßler auch 100 oder 150 jahren
noch geben wird
[Musik]
in der modernen stadt birmingham in
alabama im süden der usa steht eine
rostige industrieruine
was einem sofort ins auge springen sind
diese riesigen türme die sich aus der
landschaft erheben
wenn man das gelände betritt ist man von
metallkonstruktionen umgeben durch die
man hindurch kletterten hindurch läuft
es ist ein riesiges spinnennetz aus
rostigem metall mit empore schornsteinen
rohren und schwung reden sahen
redewendung lauter wunderschönen
gerätschaften
dazu gibt es tunnel und wassertürmen
flügel und lokomotiven
was man auf den ersten blick nicht
vermutet dieser ort stand im mittelpunkt
einer industriellen sowie auch einer
gesellschaftlichen revolution
von oben sieht man diesen gleich
knotenpunkt man kann sich auch heute
noch gut vorstellen dass die
bahnanbindung sehr bedeutend für diese
anlage war
die fabrikanlage steht symbolisch für
einen wichtigen moment in der geschichte
der usa und ist der geburtsort einer
revolution hier fand eine politische
mobilisierung statt die dann in kirchen
und schulen fortgeführt wurde
[Musik]
beeindruckende ort ist aus der asche
eines brutalen konflikt auferstanden und
repräsentiert die wiedergeburt eine
nation
[Musik]
das ganze geht zurück auf eine zeit in
der sich amerika mühsam von den
schrecken des rezessions krieges erholte
william t shirt ein bekannter general
der auf seiten der nordstaaten kämpfte
verfolgte als gnadenloser befehlshaber
eine strategie der verbrannten erde
general sherman ließ bei seinem marsch
durch die südstaaten die felder und
gebäude verwüsten ebenso wie die ersten
industriellen anlagen die gerade im
süden gebaut wurden
mit der jungen industrie in trümmern
müssen sich die südstaaten an den
wiederaufbau machen aus der asche des
amerikanischen bürgerkrieges entsteht
eine neue bewegung aus der gebeutelte
bundesstaaten wie alabama modernisiert
hervorgehen
historiker tyler maluga nie hat sich
jahrelang mit dieser entwicklung befasst
[Musik]
vor und während des bürgerkriegs war
hier praktisch nichts birmingham wurde
erst 1871 gegründet damals begann gerade
die news auf bewegung sie sollte für
erneuerung und den ausbau von industrie
im süden sorgen der süden sollte nie
wieder von gütern aus dem norden
abhängig sein nach dem motto wir hier in
birmingham produzieren die sachen die
wir brauchen selbst
mülheim herum bietet etwas besonderes
sie ist wie gemacht für die
eisenproduktion
display die lage war absolut perfekt
denn deutlich sich sehr günstig reisen
herstellen innerhalb eines radius von 50
kilometern fanden sich die drei dafür
notwendigen komponenten
eisenerz kalkstein und kohlen weltweit
gibt es nur wenige orte an denen man
alle drei rohstoffe so dicht beieinander
findet
rohstoffe sind das eine aber man
benötigt auch transportmöglichkeiten
die beste eisenproduktion nützt
natürlich nichts wenn man das eisen
nicht weg transportieren kann darum
verlaufen direkt hier die gleise ohne
anbindung an den schienenverkehr hätte
es birmingham so nie gegeben birmingham
ist die erste industriestadt der usa die
nicht direkt neben einem gewässer
entstanden ist dank der eisenbahn
kernel james sifers los spielt bei der
anbindung der gegend ans schienennetz
eine entscheidende rolle wohl auch aus
eigenem interesse denn 1882 entstehende
schloss hoch dürfen
wir stehen hier auf einem hochofen darin
wurde das eisen hergestellt
dies lausannes company wurde schnell zu
einem der größten roheisen produzenten
der welt
der herstellungsprozess ist komplex und
gefährlich
[Musik]
corinna berg von hier aus sieht man
viele stationen des produktionsablaufs
denn dafür braucht es mehr als nur einen
hochofen in riesigen metall türmen wurde
luft erhitzt und in den hochofen
geleitet um die temperatur auf 2000 grad
celsius zu bringen
auch der wasserturm war unverzichtbar
denn man brauchte wasser um den hochofen
zu kühlen damit er nicht schmilzt und um
dampf zu gewinnen der die anlage am
laufen hält
beträgt dieser ort das gesicht der stadt
das hergestellte eisen war so heiß dass
es glüht es liegt die ganze
produktionsstraße glühen und das 24
stunden am tag sieben tage die woche
um das werk am laufen zu halten wurden
viele arbeiter benötigt in einem der
gebäude finden sich noch hinweise auf
die zusammensetzung der belegschaft
das hier ist das alte pfade gebäude für
schwarze hier sollten die schwarzen
arbeiter nach der schicht duschen denn
er in birmingham herrschte
rassentrennung auf bais los
chryslers konnte schwarzer arbeitskräfte
gewinnen trotz der geringen lohn in dem
die firma ihnen zusätzlich eine
unterkunft zur verfügung stellte dazu
gemeinschaftliche einrichtungen wie
kirchen schulen und gemeindezentren die
leute arbeiteten für wenig geld denn es
gab hier kaum andere jobmöglichkeiten
zu beginn waren viele der arbeiter
ehemalige sklaven oder kinder ehemaliger
sklaven ihnen war es wichtig dass ihre
kinder eine schule besuchen konnten
darum zogen sie hierher und arbeiteten
in dieser fabrik
[Musik]
die belegschaft besteht zu über 70
prozent aus schwarzem die arbeiter sind
größtenteils in kleinen hütten
untergebracht den sogenannten schloss
quarters
wie in großen teilen der usa wird im
unternehmen strikt auf rassentrennung
geachtet es herrscht eine strenge
hierarchie
ganz oben steht eine gruppe weißer
führungskräfte dazu chemiker buchhalter
und ingenieure und ganz unten eine rein
schwarze arbeiterschaft
die rassentrennung was los war teil
eines gesamt gefüges innerhalb dessen
vieles getrennt war da braucht das nicht
unbedingt schilder durch die leute waren
daran gewöhnt bei schloss nutzen
schwarze und weiße getrennte waschräume
und stempel fuhren sie besuchen
getrennte betriebsfeiern und nicht nur
am arbeitsplatz herrscht rassentrennung
sondern in der ganzen stadt
über die zeit wird die lage zunehmend
angespannt
[Musik]
es gab einen polizeichef jugendball
corner der besonders repressiv und
brutal vorging in einer stadt in der
besonders strikt auf rassentrennung
geachtet wurde es gab so viel gewalt
dass der ort auch birmingham genannt
wurde
die stadt ist für diskriminierung
berüchtigt aber gleichzeitig hat die
firmenpolitik von unternehmen wie
schloss unbeabsichtigte auswirkungen
mit den schulen und den kirchen die in
den siedlungen der industriearbeiter
gebaut wurden setzten diese unternehmen
nicht nur die rassentrennung um sondern
schufen unbeabsichtigter weise auch orte
der begegnung und der bildung die den
menschen neue möglichkeiten eröffnet
durch die schule in kirchen und
siedlungen in der nähe der fabrik
entstanden räume in denen sich
afroamerikaner treffen und fortbilden
konnten
das war wichtig dafür dass eine art
bürgerbewegung entstehen konnte und der
grundstein für die politische
mobilisierung gelegt werden konnte geben
auch in kirchen und schulen
1963 erreichen die spannungen
schließlich ihren höhepunkt und
birmingham rückt in den fokus der
weltöffentlichkeit
martin luther king kam nach birmingham
unter anderem weil die rassentrennung
dort so strikt umgesetzt wurde und weil
die stadt besonders hart gegen schwarze
vorgänger
dr king wollte also darauf aufmerksam
machen und erreichen dass die
rassentrennung hier aufgehoben wird das
führte dazu dass sich die jugend in der
stadt gegen rassismus stark machte
der hausen der junge menschen
veranstalteten protestmärsche und wurden
von der polizei so brutal mit hunden und
wasserkanonen angegriffen dass es
weltweit aufmerksamkeit erregte
die ereignisse in birmingham tragen mit
dazu bei dass die rassentrennung in
amerika aufgehoben wird das hat auch
auswirkungen auf unternehmen wie schloss
nach dem ende der rassentrennung
herrschte zumindest auf dem papier
chancengleichheit für alle arbeiter
afroamerikaner konnten sich jetzt für
höhere positionen bewerben die sie zuvor
nicht inne haben durften die aufhebung
der rassentrennung spielte also durchaus
eine rolle in der unternehmensgeschichte
von schloss doch während in der praxis
zwar stellen auf mittlerer ebene
zugänglich werden bleibt der
aufgabenbereich schwarze arbeiter meist
auf handlanger tätigkeiten begrenzt als
in den 1970 er jahren endlich
grundlegende änderungen im arbeitsrecht
vorgenommen werden ist es zu spät da hat
in der schwerindustrie schon das große
fabrik sterben eingesetzt dass zahllose
arbeitsplätze kostet hinzu kommen neue
umweltschutz auflagen und der siegeszug
des kunststoffes
1971 ist schloss schließlich am ende und
macht dicht
[Musik]
1981 werden die hochöfen von der
regierung saniert und unter
denkmalschutz gestellt
heute stehen sie der öffentlichkeit als
museum zur verfügung
[Musik]
punkte presse die renovierung von
schloss ist in vielerlei hinsicht
wichtig die anlage dient zum einen als
zeugnis für den wiederaufbau in den
südstaaten nach dem bürgerkrieg sie ist
aber auch ein wichtiger ort in der
geschichte der bürgerrechtsbewegung und
in der geschichte schwarze arbeiter im
süden der usa
[Musik]
im mittelmeer vor der küste albaniens
liegt eine geheimnisvolle kleine insel
mit einer faszinierenden vergangenheit
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick ist es eine
typische inseln adriatischen meer hier
und dort wachsen pinien und feigenbäume
und aus der ferne sieht man schöne
kleine strände
wenn man näher kommt bemerkt man dass
die ganze insel mit hunderten wenn nicht
tausenden von kleinen betonbauten
übersät ist
neben diesen kleinen betonbunker erheben
sich auch größere gebäude
das ausmaß der bebauung wird einen erst
klar wenn man auf der insel ist
kalte betten ausrangierte
küchenutensilien verlassene schulen
an es ist kaputt und verfallen da fragt
man sich ob nur der zahn der zeit an
diesen gebäuden gemacht hat oder ob sie
womöglich im zuge militärische konflikte
schaden genommen haben
alles deutet darauf hin dass hier einst
viele menschen gelebt haben und zwar für
längere zeit
das ist eine richtige geisterstadt oder
genauer gesagt eine geisterinsel
noch dazu gibt es rätselhafte
tunnelanlagen
am boden liegen hier unter gasmasken hat
man sich auf einen atomaren oder
chemischen angriff vorbereitet
einige der gasmasken sind ganz klein als
seien sie für kinder gedacht
was also hat es mit diesem ort auf sich
und vor wem oder was hatten die
inselbewohner angst
ein blick auf die karte verrät wie
strategisch bedeutsamen die lage der
insel ist am südlichen ende der adria wo
sie sich zu einer schmalen stelle
verengt von hier aus kann man den ein
und den ausgehenden schiffsverkehr im
adriatischen meer überwachen
wer die insel unter kontrolle hatte
kontrollierte letztlich die adria
albanien hat eine bewegte geschichte der
start wurde erst 1913 anerkannt infolge
einer diplomatischen übereinkunft die
großmächte konnten sich nicht einigen ob
albanien serbien oder österreich ungarn
zugesprochen werden oder unter
türkischer herrschaft bleiben sollte
also erklärte man albanien zu einem
eigenen land aber die nachbarländer
erkennen albanien dass ein unabhängiges
fürstentum sein soll nie wirklich an
die italiener machten sich schon 1914 zu
beginn des ersten weltkriegs in albanien
breit und verstärkten dort ihre präsenz
während des krieges
dann in der zwischenzeit besetzten sie
albanien komplett
einige der gebäude lassen nach
italienischen einfluss erkennen aber die
besatzung durch italienische und ab 1943
durch deutsche soldaten endet mit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
1947 übernimmt das inzwischen
kommunistische albanien wieder die
kontrolle auf sahen der mittelmeerinsel
die aus der ferne wie ein paradies wirkt
mein büro erinnert sich an eine zeit in
der das leben hier alles andere als
unbeschwert war
[Musik]
damals wurde die insel als hüterin vor
dem kriege und als schutzpatronin für
das ganze land bezeichnet
das eiland musst also nicht nur sich
selbst und die bewohner schützen sondern
sollte der albanischen führung melden
wenn sich einen feind näherte
aber wer ist der feind
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg herrschte in
albanien eine kommunistische diktatur
die sehr eng mit der sowjetunion
verbunden war
die sowjets finanzierten enorme
militärische projekte auf der insel
sie bauten eine werft zur boot wartung
ein weitläufiges tunnelsystem tausende
biker und einen flugplatz
sie verwandelten das eiland in einer art
stehenden flugzeugträger
an der spitze des regimes stand der
albanische diktator enver hoxha er war
zwar ein verbündeter der kommunistischen
supermächte wusste aber dass sie sich
jederzeit gegen ihn wenden und albanien
einnehmen konnten
mit der zeit übernahm albanien mehr und
mehr die kontrolle auf der insel die
sowjets zogen ab aber das albanische
regime war äußerst paranoid
fürchtet ein angriff der amerikaner der
sowjets und auch der chinesin und diese
furcht manifestiert sich in all diesen
bunkern die ganze insel ist voll davon
hinter jeder ecke vermutete hoca den
feind
die albaner betrachtet die insel als
erster abwehrlinie bei einer möglichen
invasionen
[Musik]
dennoch war die insel fielen auch ein
zuhause kommandant moro erinnert sich
gern zurück an das leben hier mit seiner
frau und seinen töchtern
das war eine tolle villa es ist eine
schande sie so verfallen zu sehen
die habe ich wichtige mächtige leute
empfangen die ich eben so respektiert
habe wie sie mich ich habe sehr schöne
erinnerungen an dieses zuhause
mehr als 3000 soldaten lebten mit ihren
familien auf der insel
hier entstand eine ganz eigene
gemeinschaft
dieses gebäude hier vor uns war das
veteranen heim
hier fanden tolle kulturelle und
künstlerische veranstaltungen statt
oben war ein kino in dem drei filme pro
woche liefen aber
das gefühl dass ein angriff drohen
konnte war allgegenwärtig
der schutz der inselbevölkerung hatte
oberste priorität
die strategischen anlagen waren
hervorragend geschützt
ob waffen ausrüstung oder
versorgungsgüter alles musste
unterirdisch gelagert werden so dass man
sich im kriegsfall in die tunnel zurück
ziehen konnte
das gilt auch für die kindergärten und
schulen und die älteren leute die sich
in so einem fall um die kinder kümmern
sollten
dieser bereiche waren der teil den
schlafräumen
eine küche
eine kantine
einlage und klassenräume
es war für alles gesorgt
in der zeit des kalten krieges wurden
die tunnel angeblich auch anderweitig
verwendet
[Musik]
es gibt gerüchte sie hätten als
produktionsstätte für chemie waffen
gedient
[Musik]
penzberg emi waffen bieten sich an für
ein regime das die eigenen vernichtung
fürchtet damit lässt sich ein finaler
feindlicher angriff abwehren während
sich die inselbewohner gegen den feind
von außen wappnen droht aber auch aus
dem eigenen land gefahr
wie so viele diktatoren war ja auf dauer
nur noch darauf bedacht die eigene macht
zu sichern
er regiert mit harter hand denn er
dachte dass sich ansonsten die
bevölkerung gegen ihn wenden und ihn
töten würde
in den 1970 er jahren erreicht hodgers
paranoia ihren höhepunkt aus furcht vor
einem putsch lässt er die eigene partei
säubern und politiker und intellektuelle
hinrichten
die villa des kommunistischen
verteidigungsminister steht noch aber er
selbst wurde 1974 von zunehmend
paranoiden diktator enver hoxha als
verräter hingerichtet als
enger mitarbeiter des
verteidigungsministers schwebt auch
kommandant udo in großer gefahr
nachdem der verteidigungsminister einer
säuberungsaktion zum opfer gefallen war
fürchteten verständlicherweise alle die
enge verbindungen zu ihm hatten dass sie
die nächsten sein könnten
aber kommandant moro wird erst 1985
ganze elf jahre später verhaftet und als
staatsfeind verurteilt
1989 kommt er aus der haft frei
rechtzeitig um den zusammenbruch des
letzten kommunistischen staates in
europa mitzuerleben
[Musik]
viele schäden hier gehen auf jüngere
übungen britischer und albanischer
marine truppen zurück
aber die insel ist nicht länger nur in
militärischer hand
kasan ist touristisch sehr interessant
daher hat man die insel für besucher
geöffnet
jetzt kann man sich die
militärgeschichte ganz aus der nähe
ansehen
eine der amerikanischen jungferninseln
an der nordküste dieses karibischen
paradieses finden sich seltsam anmutende
ruinen
der strand ist völlig unberührt ein
tropisches paradies aber
landeinwärts stößt man auf überwucherte
anlagen
dort stehen fast verborgen von
palmwedeln und lianen mehrere mauern mit
fenster und türöffnungen
das war früher nicht einfach nur ein
weitläufiges haus sondern etwas viel
komplexeres
der schornstein und die verbindungswege
deuten auf eine industrielle anlage hin
war dies einst ein industriegelände und
was hat es mit diesem großen steinernen
mauerring auf sich die exakte runde form
lässt vermuten dass sie für einen
bestimmten zweck gebaut wurde aber für
welchen
nicht weit davon entfernt nahe dem
wasser steht eine weitere ruine
der sonntag steht noch ein gebäude aus
stein ohne erkennbare verbindung dazu
beide weisen dieselbe stein bauweise auf
aber es ist nicht ersichtlich in welcher
verbindung die beiden orte miteinander
standen
welchen zweck erfüllten die gebäude und
liefern die beschädigungen daran einen
hinweis darauf warum man sie im
dschungel einfach verrotten ließ
[Musik]
die geschichte dieser kleinen insel ist
geprägt von einer zeit in der
europäische länder auf entdeckungs und
expansionskurs waren
im 17 jahrhundert teilten europäische
mächte die karibik unter sich auf samt
ihrer ressourcen und in dieser gegend
hier ließen sich die dänen nieder
die dänischen siedler sehen sich mit
vielfältigen herausforderungen und
gefahren konfrontiert
es gab hans und erdbeben und fast kein
trinkwasser auf der insel viele
bezahlten die reise mit dem leben waren
aber offensichtlich bereit das risiko
einzugehen
hier konnte man etwas herstellen das
damals wertvoller war als gold und so
abhängig machte wie eine droge wer diese
industrie sollte ihren eigentümern nicht
nur wohlstand bringen sondern das
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
gefüge der westlichen welt verändern
ohne den reichtum der hier in der
karibik gewonnen wurde wäre die
industrielle revolution nicht möglich
gewesen der erwirtschaftete reichtum
fließt nach europa aber für andere in
der karibik hat die entstehung dieser
neuen industrie schlimme auswirkungen
wie der ranger can wild bei näherer
untersuchung der ruinen festgestellt hat
dieser kleine bereich hier war wohl so
eine art kerker in den menschen
festgehalten wurden
aber für einige war dies auf ihre
behausung wer waren die menschen die
hier unter solchen bedingungen leben
mussten und warum waren sie hier
die dänen konnten nicht auf einheimische
arbeitskräfte zurückgreifen und eigene
brachten sie auch nicht mit stattdessen
kauften sie fast klaffte afrikaner you
would have diese menschen hatten nicht
nur eine unglaublich beschwerliche lange
beengte und lebensgefährliche reise über
den atlantik hinter sich sondern mussten
dann vor allem während der erntezeit oft
18 bis 20 stunden am tag arbeiten
dies ist die cinema plantage
hier wurde zuckerrohr angebaut und
verarbeitet
die zucker und die sklaven industrie
waren eng miteinander verflochten
man brauchte viele und billige
arbeitskräfte um mit zucker gewinn zu
erwirtschaften
dass so viele sklaven in die karibik
verschleppt wurden lag unter anderem
daran dass dort so viele starben denn
die arbeitsbedingungen waren todbringend
auf der insel lebten 4000 arbeitslosen
unter schrecklichen bedingungen die
strafen für jedes noch so kleine
vergehen waren drakonisch
die zuckerherstellung ist ein sehr
anfällige prozess man braucht arbeiter
die extrem diszipliniert genau das tun
was man will und wann man es will
die kräftezehrende arbeit begann in den
dichten wäldern hochgewachsenen
zuckerrohrs die meisten menschen haben
noch nie eine machete geschwungen und
zuckerrohr geschnitten das ist eine der
schwersten landwirtschaftlichen
tätigkeiten hier wurden die pflanzen
nach oben zur verarbeitung transportiert
dort kam der noch heute sichtbare
ringförmige bau ins spiel
wir stehen hier auf einer mühle hier
liefen tiere im kreis herum und trieben
so die walzen an diese runden bauten
finden sich auf der ganzen insel
in jeder werde müde brauchte man vier
arbeiter einer trieb die tiere an zwei
sorgten für nachschub an den walzen und
ein vierter entfernte die aus gepressten
zuckerrohr äste die sogenannte bagasse
aus dem saft wurde dann der äußerst
lukrative brauner rohrzucker gewonnen
aber auf sein john braut sich im jahr
1733 auch ärger zusammen
angesichts der furchtbaren bedingungen
überrascht es wenig dass sklaven
anfingen einen aufstand zu planen
die dänische westindien kompanie hatte
nur sechs soldaten zur bewachung der
gesamten insel abgestellt sie waren
hoffnungslos in der minderheit die
revolte begann auf einer plantage namens
coral bay und erreichte irgendwann das
vor
der aufstand dauerte nicht nur sehr
lange erforderte auch viele todesopfer
und sorgte für große verwüstungen und
ein drittel der weißen einwohner kam ums
leben und etwa die hälfte der plantagen
wurde zerstört
die dänen hatten nicht die nötige
schlagkraft um dagegenzuhalten
daher ließen sie sich von französischen
und schweizer siedlern helfen
die aufständischen lieferten ihnen einen
zehnwöchigen kampf im frühjahr stil bis
am 23 august 1734 schließlich der letzte
von ihnen gefasst wurde
nachdem der aufstand niedergeschlagen
ist werden die strafen und grausamkeiten
noch schlimmer
man will ein exempel statuieren
aber letztlich brachte die
einschüchterungstaktik nichts die
karibische zuckerindustrie wurde bis zur
abschaffung der sklaverei durch die
briten 1834 immer wieder von aufständen
gebeutelt im laufe des 19 jahrhunderts
ging es mit der zuckerindustrie in der
karibik bergab auch weil die europäer
mit dem anbau und der verarbeitung von
zuckerrüben ihren zucker bedarf
zunehmend aus eigener kraft stillen
viele jahrzehnte lang bleiben die
gebäude sich selbst und der natur
überlassen bis die us-regierung den
denen die insel 1955 abkauft und weite
teile zum nationalpark erklärt
dies ist dann unglaublich bedeutender
ort einer der wenigen auf dem
amerikanischen kontinent der jetzt teil
der usa ist an denen man den schauplatz
eines sklavenaufstand besuchen kann eine
sehr früh sehr langen und sehr großen
aufstand
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]